when it comes to mathematical genius
there is one name you need to know
and that is of srinivasa ramanujan
he was a remarkable mathematician and
could see connections between numbers
that nobody else could see ramanujan was
a self-taught indian man who despite
having no
formal education in mathematics reached
out to a cambridge professor
in the form of this letter and described
some of his
ideas that professor g h
hardy was able to recognize ramanujan's
genius
and invited him from india to come over
to england
and work with him they had a really
productive
collaboration that spanned many years
and
since this letter is what started such a
remarkable story
i thought today i would show you through
exactly what ramanujan said to hardy
that enabled hardy to recognize his
genius
and be so excited about it the letter
starts off with
a cover page followed by about 11
pages of mathematics now a couple of
these pages have now been lost
along with the original cover letter but
what i have here
is a transcription published by hardy
let's just have a read of this first
paragraph here
it begins dear sir i beg to introduce
myself to you
as a clerk in the accounts department of
the port trust office of madras
on a salary of only 20 pounds per annum
i am now about 23 years of age
i have had no university education but i
have undergone the ordinary school
course
after leaving school i have been
employing the spare time at my disposal
to work at mathematics i have not
trodden through the conventional regular
course which has followed in a
university course
but i am striking out a new path for
myself
i have made a special investigation of
divergent series in general
and the results i get are termed by the
local mathematicians
as startling now g h hardy whose first
initial stand for godfrey harold
is one of england's leading pure
mathematicians
and ramanujan is trying to introduce
himself to hardy in such a way
that hardy understands where he's coming
from that he's kind of on the back foot
with his situation and tries to interest
hardy in taking him seriously
hardy like many mathematicians back then
as well as now
would probably receive many such letters
from people
claiming to have discovered great things
or to be
their own kind of genius and it's
probably quite hard to tell
who is the real deal let's now have a
look at the second section of the letter
and it was actually rather unpromising
ramanujan goes on to describe a result
that he must have thought was one of his
best
but was actually well known at the time
he is describing something called the
gamma function
which is really an extension of the
factorial function
for the factorial function which we
would write as n
factorial if n was say
five then this would be equal to
five times four times three
times two times one the gamma function
could also be written as
n minus one factorial so if we were to
do the gamma
of 5 it would be equal to 4
times 3 times 2 times 1.
if this is our complex plane with real
numbers and imaginary numbers
the gamma function is well defined on
this whole
right hand area for all complex numbers
with positive real part what ramanujan
is describing with this equation here
is a way to extend this function
to also be defined in this left-hand
side
area in this case that would be for all
negative values of z
except for the negative integers if we
draw a plot
of zed versus the gamma ray z we see it
is indeed well defined
on all of these positive numbers and for
all of the fractional negative numbers
but these dashed lines are the negative
integers where the function is not
defined
now this trick of extending the domain
of a function
actually is called analytic continuation
and was well known as a technique at the
time and
doing analytic continuation you would
get exactly what ramanujan has written
here
so although it is not a new result
ramanujan has
independently come up with something
that is useful to mathematicians without
having
access to the papers in which it would
have been published
let's take a look at this final
paragraph here
in which ramanujan says that he's come
across an article written by hardy
in which there is a statement that no
definite expression
has been as yet found for the number of
primes less than any given number
i have found an expression which very
nearly approximates to the real result
the error being negligible i would
request you to go
through the enclosed papers being poor
if you are convinced that there is
anything of value i would like to have
my theorems published
i have not given the actual
investigations
nor the expressions that i get but i
have indicated the lines on which i
proceed
being inexperienced i would very highly
value
any advice you give me requesting to be
excused for the trouble i give you
i remain dear sir yours truly
s ramanujan so what he is talking about
here in the third paragraph is about the
distribution of prime numbers
if we want to find how many prime
numbers there are
less than or equal to a certain given
number x
then we would denote that with the prime
counting function
denoted pi of x what we have is a bit of
a
step function where every time we
find or count a new prime number we add
one to the telly
and many great mathematicians have tried
to come up with a function that would
accurately approximate this
ramanujan goes into a bit more detail
about his technique
in the first couple of pages of his
working
these are copies that i have here the
originals being stored at the cambridge
university library
ramanujan claimed that he could easily
calculate the number of prime
numbers up to 100 millions with
generally no error
and in some cases with an error of one
or two
now it turns out that his prime counting
technique was not
quite as precise as he claimed it to be
but still was
some really great mathematics so perhaps
those first two results
mentioned in the cover letter were not
so promising
but ramanujan then goes on to give over
a hundred
more results that shows just how
prolific he
is in coming up with ideas and just how
much work he's already done on this
third page here we have the formulas for
many
sums and integrals that ramanujan
considers to be
interesting on this last page we have
talk of divergent series
and we have written down the now
infamous result
that one plus two plus three plus four
and so on is equal to minus one over
twelve
and you might have heard of this
seemingly absurd result
i'll link to some videos about it in the
description as well
ramanujan himself acknowledges that to
add up
all of the positive integers and get a
result that isn't positive infinity
seems quite absurd but his confidence in
his own methods
meant that he didn't shy away from
presenting this to hardy
after receiving the letter from
ramanujan hardy consulted with his
friend and collaborator littlewood a
quote from littlewood was that
these results must be true because no
one would have the imagination to invent
them
it was littlewood who also went on to
later say that
every positive integer was one of
ramanujan's personal friends
in hardy's first response to ramanujan
he says that he was exceedingly
interested by his letter
and by the theorems which he stated
however he says that before he can judge
them
he must see proofs of some of the
acetations
hardy then groups the results into three
categories
these are number one results which are
already known
number two results which are new
but not that important and number three
results that are new and potentially
important
but hardy insists that all of this
relies on being able to see some proofs
of this work
he put quite a few of the results into
that first category of things that were
already known
and ramanujan later said that that
actually made him really happy
because to see that some of his results
were indeed already known
verified them as being correct and true
because even he himself might have been
a bit unsure of a few of them
in category 2 these are the ones that
are new but
not very important and the only thing
that makes it into category 3
being new and important is this
expression about finding the number of
primes
less than a given x he asks ramanujan to
send him some proofs as
quickly as possible and acknowledges
that he has done a good deal of work
worth publication he also includes at
the end of his reply
some notes suggested by littlewood after
a bit more back and forth ramanujan is
invited over to england to join hardy
and littlewood
and work on publishing some of these
results
ramanujan unfortunately only lived a
short life
and so the things that were able to be
published while he was alive
were only a small portion of the work
that he'd done
but many years on i believe that
mathematicians can still
find lots of gems written down in
ramanujan's notebooks
some of his results might seem at first
like random mathematical facts but many
of them
indeed give insight into unexpected and
surprising relationships
between patterns of numbers i hope you
have found it interesting to take a look
at this letter which
revealed a genius thank you for watching
and a special thank you to the viewers
who support me on patreon
it is your support that makes these
videos possible to make
at all also a special shout out
to today's patreon cat of the day
stella